[Música]
hoy el expresidente de Brasil Jair
bolsonaro se presenta ante el tribunal
superior electoral por difundir
afirmaciones sin fundamentos sobre la
seguridad del sistema de votación
bolsonaro nunca reconoció la victoria de
Luis Ignacio Lula Silva y está acusado
además de inspirar a miles de sus
seguidores a invadir edificios
gubernamentales en Brasil y el pasado 8
de enero la conversación sobre este tema
es con Oscar Milena doctor en ciencias
políticas por la universidad de Sao
Paulo bienvenido France 24 Qué
consecuencias enfrenta bolsonaros y
pierde este caso y en qué posición llega
a la comparecencia
impedido desde ser sus derechos
políticos por los próximos ocho años no
es un juicio de naturaleza penal es un
juicio de naturaleza electoral Brasil
tiene una estructura de la justicia
electoral era un código electoral que
prevé algunas penalidades para delitos
electorales en los delitos cometidos por
bolsonaro es los delitos de atentar
contra la integridad del sistema
electoral algo que ha hecho año pasado
cuando era candidato a presidente de la
república
Bueno bolsonaro también enfrenta
múltiples investigaciones criminales que
podrían ponerlo tras las rejas y su
defensa pues está culpando de alguna
manera a la prensa por esta situación
difícil Usted qué opina
ron ha cometido una serie de delitos de
naturaleza política que podrían ser a
juzgados por los Congreso Nacional con
los efectos del pero no fue porque había
un control sobre la cámara y lo
presidente de la cámara no colocó más de
una centena de pedidos de impeachmann a
por crines de responsabilidad como se
dicen en Brasil hay un otro conjunto de
crímenes que tiene naturaleza penal
común que fueron los crímenes
practicados durante la pandemia mucho a
los ejemplo más grave Es toda la campaña
que ha hecho contra la las vacunas con
las consecuencias de desastrosas durante
la pandemia entonces bolsonaro tiene
crímenes electorales
de responsabilidad que son crímenes del
ejercicio de la presidencia propiamente
dicho en los crímenes penales Ah o qué
está enfrentando ahora tribunal
electoral es también a un conjunto de
crímenes comunes que irá iniciar como
Trump a responder en los próximos meses
Bueno cómo podrían reaccionar Los
Seguidores de bolsonaro ante este
proceso ya hemos visto comportamientos
violentos en el pasado como lo que
estábamos diciendo del 8 de enero en
Brasilia
Bueno hay una una reducción de la
radicalidad porque bolsonaronaron
incitaba la violencia incitaba actos
hostiles contra los poderes
constitucionales siempre una amenaza de
que los militares y dieron Sin mover
herido apoyar a su convocación para
afrontar la Constitución
convocionados fuera del poder con los
militares siendo cumplido la
Constitución que no mostrado la lealtad
a los poderes constitucionales creo que
no hay una posibilidad de una reacción a
mucho a efectiva Claro que podemos ser
manifestaciones de apoyadores más leales
frente a los tribunales pero no veo ni
una posibilidad de que haya una una una
reacción que pueda colocar en el riesgo
sustento la jurisdicción del tribunal
electoral como la Constitución bueno
algo que llama la atención es que el
expresidente se pronunció previo al
inicio de este proceso y dijo que él
pensaba que esto iba a enviar un mensaje
demostrando la democracia en Brasil
usted como analiza este mensaje del ex
mandatario
sí los mandatario es un populista de
sistema de derecho clásico que hay
siempre buscado deslegitimar a las
instituciones Entonces desde lo inicio
de su gobierno
Ya producía que en algún momento las
cortes de Justicia irán a aplacar su su
vida política Ese es una forma
evidentemente de alguien que tiene una
estrategia de violación de la
Constitución de anticipar cualquier
resultado y sufas parte de su narrativa
entonces a peso que hoy va sonaron tenga
una popularidad muy grande porque es un
representante de la derecha brasileña
que es una una derecha robusta para
decir lo mínimo es un poco la o lo que
identifica la extrema derecha y la
derecha pienso que los procesos
políticos brasileño ha otros candidatos
de derecha que eran ocupar su espacio en
la medida en que su vida política está
por terminar por lo menos de los
próximos de la próxima década bueno algo
que llama la atención es este apoyo que
tuvo el expresidente bolsonaro de las
iglesias evangélicas y que en este
momento las estamos viendo bastante
silenciosas
sí las iglesias evangélicas crecieron
mucho en los últimos años en Brasil las
últimas décadas en Brasil a una parte de
los evangélicos no son todos pero una
parte de los evangélicos tiene valores
muy conservadores eh bozonaron consiguió
una medida capturar a a a su atención a
reforzando un discurso eminentemente
conservador a la cuestión que que que
que que que aparece en Brasil en ese
momento ese subirán otros candidatos
también conservadores pero que no sea
antidemocrático eso qué sería un avanzo
muy grande que la derecha pudiese ser
representada por candidatos
conservadores pero que no entre en
conflicto con con la Constitución
entonces Brasil de facto todas las
encuestas de monstruo hizo es un país
que cambió mucho a la derecha en las
últimas décadas esto tiene una relación
también con lo crecimiento de
determinadas a iglesias evangélicas
bueno Y de alguna manera podría
bolsonaro como Donald Trump en Estados
Unidos capitalizar este proceso como una
narrativa de ataques y que al final lo
fortalezcan que fortalezcan su imagen
sí
es una una imitación
tropical de de Donald no hay ni una duda
trabaje a partir de la misma estrategias
exactamente lo que tú dices que quiere
hacer a la que yo sí funcionará o no eh
También Cómo se comportaron los otros a
representantes de la derecha que están
en competición Para ocupar su lugar tal
vez la diferencia es que Trump tenga una
lideresa tal vez menos contestable tu
punto de vista de la derecha equipo
solar dará competidores Como por ejemplo
lo gobernador de San Pablo que fue su
ministro es una figura de derecha
bastante extrema pero a que trabaja con
una una estética menos agresiva que
puede ser interesante para para la
derecha brasilera Entonces ese es un
poco sí es muy parecido con los procesos
de Trump bueno Y si hablamos digamos en
campaña cuando estaba esta campaña de
Lula Silva y esta campaña los ataques
eran frontales entre los dos pero ahora
Lula al frente del ejecutivo qué
posición tiene respecto a estos procesos
de bolsonaro
Lula tiene un comportamiento bastante
tranquilo hasta porque la justicia
brasileña asumió la responsabilidad
durante todo el proceso del gobierno
bolsonaro de contello en en las acciones
que eran inconstitucionales los supremo
tribunal Federal tiene un protagonismo
yo diría en común para cortes en
democracias porque
difato fue lo poder que más una
contención de bolsonaro eh A partir del
Ocho de enero cuando hubo la tentativa
de golpe también los supremos tribunal
asumió porque fue invadido físicamente
la competencia es del supremo tribunal
Federal de defenderse cuando su su
integridad es atacada Los Inquietos ya
hay más de mil personas que están hoy
haciendo a a procesadas criminalmente
por actos
a tentativa de
eliminarlo está derecho y la democracia
entonces Lula ha mantido un cerdo
silencio porque hay una conducta
bastante protagonista de la justicia no
es necesario que lo presidente use sus
energías para combatir los vocionalismo
los vocionalismo está haciendo combatido
en los en las partes pues señor Milena
usted muchas gracias por su análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en France
creo que agradezco y a ustedes también
Muchas gracias por su sintonía y por
acompañarnos hacemos otra pausa aquí en
directo a América ya regresamos
[Música]